[Music]
blue ivy carter crashes her famous
parents date night in a new video
celebrating tiffany and company i'm very
happy the short film which is less than
two minutes long features jay-z and
beyonce in a scene inspired by breakfast
at tiffany's he loves me
he loves peanut
the date night video follows the couple
as they have a flirty drive around new
york city
oh monty can you pull over please
this is so sweet
shall we have pizza i think we need
pizza
[Music]
we need champagne we need champagne
like real champagne i mean
[Music]
and that's when their nine-year-old
daughter who's adorably sporting braces
hops in the back of the car and crashes
their date
hey
[Music]
and just when you thought it couldn't
get any cuter the couple hits us with
this
[Music]
[Music]
of course j and b have been together for
over 20 years and have been married for
over a decade
[Music]
and throughout their relationship
they've collaborated a bunch both in
music and business
and when e.t caught up with jay in
august he opened up about why he loves
working with his wife she's a
super
detail oriented obviously as you can see
from her work and she's a incredibly
hard worker
super talented
very inspiring and that work ethic goes
both ways e.t chatted with the rapper in
la last week at a special screening for
the harder they fall a movie jay
produced and he opened up about helping
create an action-packed western with a
predominantly black cast
let's start what we have come into the
room to do
right
here
one in three cowboys in the west was
black people don't know that growing up
like one of the only things on you know
public television was westerns every
week you would get western so
um and we weren't we weren't represented
in those in those at all um in fact you
know you know our characters was taken
from us you know the lone ranger was
based on you know one of the characters
from this film i just love to be a part
of projects that widen the lens you know
because once it's widened for us then
it's widened for you know asian for
you know mexican for everyone
[Music]